[Music]
whether it's their flexibility
strength or memory these human beings
have real-life
superpowers here are five stories where
people achieve
the impossible
my name is ianni sikonoma i'm from
greece and i speak 32 languages
russian portuguese norwegian turkish
hungarian
czech police ionis is what we call a
hyper polyglot it means he can speak
a lot of languages by the time i was 20
i'd already
learned some 15 languages
and when i moved to brussels and started
my career at the eu institutions i
added more official eu languages see the
thing is
i honest he's a quick learner
uen this doesn't happen by just sitting
at home and studying though
[Music]
[Music]
the world is a big place with different
cultures and yes
different languages it cleveland living
in northern sprakan another italian
anita marinetal i speak to my husband in
polish because he's polish
i dream in all kinds of languages
before we go if anyone knows it's you
what is the most complicated language to
learn
mandarin mystery solved
[Music]
to me walking upside down on all fours
is as easy as walking on two feet
it's not scary or frightening to me in
the least
i've always been flexible but not just a
little bit flexible i'm
i'm really flexible little did i know
that this ability was in fact a talent
that would change my life completely
[Music]
i'm troy james and i'm a creature actor
i play creatures on tv and movies
that move in ways that make the audience
squirm
my talent is that all of my joints my
legs my arms my shoulders
my fingers they just bend however i want
them to
so if you need an alien demon or
a non-human creature that doesn't move
in ways that normal human people do
that's when you call me it looks like
what i do
is extremely painful really it doesn't
hurt at all
i don't know why i am as flexible as i
am
it's just something i was born with i'm
the only one in my family who can bend
his arms and legs the way i do
i didn't think it was that strange until
other kids
told me it was but they weren't very
nice about it and i remember being very
embarrassed and i hid it away because
what makes you different when you're
growing up isn't something to be proud
of
i hid it for a long time
that all changed when i got a job as an
amusement park
ride operator it was a hot day
the ride was down for some reason or
another the guests were getting
kind of ornery and i thought why don't i
show them what i could do
and i went up and down the line making
really cool shapes with my body and
it was a hit and that was the first time
i'd gotten that sort of positive
reaction from other people
showcasing my talent i never thought my
ability was anything more than a really
cool party trick
my friend put his camera up to me and
said show me something cool
then he posted it on the internet and
all of a sudden my phone started ringing
i started getting calls to be cast in tv
shows
and i didn't look back
if you told me a year ago i was going to
be an actor
i would have laughed at you but after
some of my performances
people have told me that it's not just
the way i move my body that's effective
it's the acting behind it i bring a
reaction of the audience
i can throw them so to speak coming from
a place where
you were ostracized as i was as a child
i can bring that out as a creature
it's interesting that something that i
hid for so long
is now taking me places that i never
imagined i would
go i believe everyone has a superpower
and you may not know it's a superpower
but if it's something that you're
passionate about makes you happy
i think sharing it with the world may
not be such a bad idea after all
[Music]
at first glance you might think that
these were photographs
but these are pencil drawings part of a
growing art movement called hyper
realism when people look at my drawings
i would love them to feel
a sense of emotion um reality
you know using my works to bring people
down to earth
[Music]
my name is arenze stanley and i am a
hyper realistic artist
hyper realism is a genre of art that
involves
making drawings or paintings that
looks very realistic and you can't
actually
distinguish it from a photograph or
reality
i started drawing when i was six years
old my dad owns a paper factory
i basically grew up around a lot of
paper
when people see my works they are
usually shocked that it's not a photo
they go like oh wow is that a photo
did you make that with a pencil and i'm
like
yeah usually my works take a long time
to create
sometimes i can make a piece for about a
month
sometimes it could drag onto two months
depending on
my mood and the size of the piece
i like to use my works to speak on
issues affecting my society
here in nigeria and the whole of africa
use the voice that i have through my art
to speak for people who can speak for
themselves
this person is totally engulfed in oil
this signifies i want to use oil and
destroy our society this signifies the
sea no evil hear no evil and speak no
evil
i'm encouraging people to take a step
back and
try to emulate their childhood
trying to make people reset to default
when i pick up my pencil i put it on
paper
it takes me away it's something i can't
explain words
i'm stephen wilsher i do drawings
steven is an artist who creates
incredibly intricate drawings of
cityscapes
i love drawing tall buildings tall
skyscrapers
skylines street scenes
and he does this entirely from memory
when stephen was three he was diagnosed
as autistic
he was completely mute and lived
entirely in his own world
early on stephen's teachers noticed he
loved to draw
he had found his way to connect with
others
stephen has the ability to look at a
subject once and then draw an
accurate and detailed picture of it
including panoramas of entire cities
based off just a quick look i'll go up
on the helicopter
and then memorize it and then after
being on a helicopter and then
straight back at the hotel and then
started to draw
his incredible talent launched an
artistic career that has taken him
around the world
los angeles dubai houston texas
and tokyo and japan and that's just to
name a few
new york's my favorite empire state
building
chrysler building and there are lots of
yellow
new york taxi cabs and stephen has no
plans of stopping anytime soon
someone told me that people likes me
drawings
feel good always be happy about it
[Music]
this is myron hi
myron is an athlete i played a little
football in college
and i was a rhodes scholar and
i played for the nfl and i have a
master's degree in
medical anthropology and and i'm a
neurosurgeon
sheesh
my first dream was to play professional
football
there's no question i was very active as
a young man
and i knew that i was pretty good at it
when i got to the fifth grade
that's when i knew i wanted to pursue my
second dream i read a book called gifted
hands by ben carson who looked like me
he was black
who came from a similar socio-economic
background as me you know we didn't have
much money when we left the bahamas and
came to america and the more i read
about it the more i knew that
once i was done playing football
neurosurgery was going to be the pathway
in the second chapter of my life
i was the number one rated high school
player in the country for football
recruited by everyone 83 scholarship
offers i always felt
that football fed academics academics
fed football
myron spent his college years playing
football and shadowing doctors
he graduated in two and a half years and
was expected to be a first or second
round draft pick in the nfl with a
multi-million dollar contract
but he also had a chance to study at
oxford as a rhodes scholar
i ended up deciding to go to oxford and
saying no to the nfl
i spent a year and a half over there
came back to the united states
went into the draft and got drafted in
the sixth round instead of the second or
first
made seventy thousand dollars instead of
six million played for three years
got out healthy felt good about my time
there
frankly made enough money to pay for
medical school i didn't have any lasting
concussions and my hands were okay where
i was able to do surgeries in the
operating room
and so i left on my own volition started
medical school and here i am now
since head injuries are common on the
football field myron works to impress
the importance of avoiding concussions
on young players
but for myron his days of tackling are
behind him
football was great for that season of my
life but now this is it
this is the pinnacle this is this is
where i belong and i've told my parents
several times over and over again
they asked me myer how do you feel what
you're doing now how do you feel i said
mommy and daddy
i feel like this is where i belong so
did you say you played a sport before
yes